i voted for biden back in 2020
and i seriously regret it in 2020 i
voted for joe biden
and i now see that as a mistake i voted
for biden in 2020 and i definitely
regret voting for him i would not do it
again
folks
the people of this nation have spoken
they've delivered us a clear victory
growing up i thought that democrats were
for everybody you know especially
specifically for black people
and i kind of had that i was programmed
in the sense with that democratic you
know savior
type of situation going into you know
2020 election i was
i was for all for white and that's who i
about voted for i was like okay bite is
gonna have change he's he's you know for
everyone
and i was underneath the impression
that
he was he was going he was going to do
what he was going to say he was going to
do and not you know be lying i just i
just found out the hard way
unfortunately that you know binding was
isn't who he says he is and that it
seems like
democrats in a sense they just want to
keep us
in the same spot in the same place
more so dependent on them depending on
the government
and
i just feel like
as a whole we're just stagnant black
people were kind of trapped and we're
trapped in the divisive cycle of
believing
what democrats tell us and that's what i
was for my whole entire life you know i
believed everything they told me i
believe they're gonna
make things better and if you look at
the
track record of history
they really haven't they haven't done
anything for us for anybody really
i i started noticing that i made a huge
mistake voting for biden
uh
really just a couple of months after
biden biden took office and it was a
combination of a number of things
uh
part of it was just the handling of the
pandemic
it was the handling of the economy
it was it's inflation
it's because i voted for someone who's
essentially furthering marxist
marxist ideas in our in our country that
that i regret voting for him i mean it
really was a terrible choice
i'm inclined to think that there are
still democrats who believe in the agent
who believe in agency and autonomy of
the individual i think that but i think
a lot of the party has been
taken over
and appropriated
by
marxist
and it that's that's not a controversial
thing to say just simply
a person simply has to look at the
policies a person simply has to
well read paulo frierry or herbert
marcuse and then see all of the academic
papers coming out of ed schools that
cite those two that cite those two
marxist scholars um so back in 2020 it
was the first time i ever actually
decided to vote and i did vote for joe
biden
um because of all the promises he had
made
his main point was he's going to help
the poor people but um and that the
stimulus check
but um
we didn't get the full stimulus check
that he had promised us he didn't keep
any of his promises he's not helping the
poor the poor getting poorer i'm i'm the
poor and i'm getting poorer so
i can barely afford to eat groceries are
expensive gas is expensive like how is
gas five dollars a gallon couchsurf
right now i kind of stay with my
boyfriend and his mom my son lives with
my parents like i i don't want my son to
have like a homeless mom you know
but it seems like
everyone's going to be homeless soon
like
it's so scary where the world is going
um and it makes it it makes me seem like
what kind of future do our kids have i
used to be a biting supporter i'm
definitely a supporter anymore i was
anti-trump i thought he was a horrible
person i found out
completely false you know i
told i believe that he was racist he was
a sexist you know womanizer just all
these terrible things
just from the news and media lying on
them
i feel like i had been lied to by the
media
telling us biden's the
answer to the all the country's problems
like that's
what i saw him as when i voted for him
and um they made trump kind of the bad
guy in the media
but
things were a lot better when he was
president i cannot see any reason why i
would be voting
democrat in the next election
as far as
looking at 2024
[Music]
i'm hoping desantis runs
and he will have my vote
if
trump
runs again and wins the primary he will
have my vote as well
i would actually you know i'd see myself
definitely voting for trump if he were
to run i won't be voting for biden again
that's for sure
[Music]
you